for a fraction of a second konach's gaze
locked with his
amos saw base animal pleasure in the man
the joy of a schoolboy burning ants with
his magnifying glass
faster than anything human kanechek
dropped the dead guard and surged
forward his feet digging into the slick
mud as he ran
amos stepped into the attack which
wasn't what the guy had expected and got
a solid punch in under his rib cage
but then konach's elbow came out of
nowhere and hit amos's ear hard enough
that the world started spinning amos
stumbled and the other guy's grip was on
his belt and
arm amos felt himself lifted up over
konochek's head
he looked down the shaft and saw rona
looking up at him
wide-eyed and open mouth the black was a
long way down
amos wondered if he'd see lydia again
when he got to the bottom
probably not but it was pretty as the
last thought amos was on his feet again
knees bent deep to keep his center of
gravity low
the world was still spinning he couldn't
trust his inner ear to tell him which
way was up but he'd spent a lot of years
in free fall
ignoring vertigo just meant it was a day
that ended in y
he landed a straight kick in konach's
crotch that probably castrated him
in the man stepped back eyes wide hey
guys pete here
so what's new i think it goes without
saying that it would have been hard to
outdo the tension of the last
installment but the expanse season 5
episode 5 did what it had to do each
member of the rossi crew is dealing with
the individual crisis
they find themselves in basically right
after the rocks hit earth
and as we heard on the news feed on
drummer's ship the worst is almost
certainly yet to come we'll get started
with drummer but a quick warning
if you aren't caught up with the expanse
through season 5 episode 5 then this
video is not for you
go home in yolata and stay there until
you watch it
then of course come back watch the video
and join the discussion in the comments
with that out of the way let's talk
about this on the dewalt we see the news
reports making their way
out into the system and i still feel the
need to be cautious and speculating
about how bad things are going off these
early reports
the thing about book five is that it
happens in a really short amount of time
the thing i would use to frame it is
like two weeks or less
and i imagine that we'll see things
escalate continually
as systems break down think of that
cascade effect that prax talked about
we hear from the news feed on drummer's
ship that power systems and
desalinization infrastructures are
starting to fail
the other takeaway from the sequence is
that we see a bunch of belters who
aren't already
allied with marco and the free navy
taking this information in
there's recognition that this is a
horrible event but the resentment from
an oppressed class of people
is there it's present drummer receives a
message from marco
and agrees to go meet him and with her
dealing with the idea that she let marco
go
and that fred is dead we're seeing a lot
of interesting dynamics that exist
in this group she's their captain but
this isn't a regular crew
they're in a familial intimate
relationship together
so there's a lot of potential for drama
there we see a contrast to their
reaction
with the prison guard in amos and
peaches story
there amos is realizing that he probably
should have jumped on a ship right after
he had his realization about lydia
because now he's right in the middle of
it with the help of the guards and this
guy's connects mods
they're able to make their way up an
emergency ladder to the surface and
where the prison building used to be
we get our first look at the devastation
and then konach turns on the group
because yeah he's trying to escape
he kills the first guard throws rona's
gun down the shaft
amos makes a move but he's no match for
the guy's power
and peaches tries to use her implants
but it's too
soon the blockers are still in effect
and she just basically
slumps over on the ground there's a
moment there where amos is probably
regretting calling conocheck tiny as
he's about to get tossed
but rona's able to override the
biometric lock on the gun by using
the other guard's finger to pull the
trigger that buys enough time for amos
to kick him in the crotch
and then end him with a suplex
considering that amos is 100 focused on
survival
peaches is just enjoying the win because
she never thought she'd feel it again
rona is the perfect person to show us an
earther's
reaction she's got family who were
nearby while this happened
she's in shock just taking in the
destruction that's all around her
and with a little encouragement from
amos she basically just wanders off to
go find out what happened
and what i like about this is you can
just think about how many people there
are
all over this planet who are doing the
exact same thing
on taiko holden can't get a hold of
anyone he's trying to reach naomi
he hasn't heard from his family back on
earth and he's in the middle of some
chaos there because fred has
died so he goes with bull to interview
sakai to see what they can learn she
doesn't give away anything that will
help them
but she does drive home how much hate
some belters have for people from the
inner planets
while they're talking holden gets a
message from monica
who used her eye camera mod to capture
the zamiya's flight plan
and there's a really great piece of
acting here where we see sakai
realize what's about to happen of course
she was working on the rossi
and she even mentioned in a conversation
with naomi in episode 1 that they had
updated the software
and so now she knows that they're going
to leave and the code that she put in
there will kill them
for a second she almost tells them
because she knows that this is
basically going to be her death sentence
since she's in custody
if she had a moment to help herself out
in the situation this would be
it and you see the look on her face
change as she doubles her resolve
and tells them see you when you get back
one of the things i really love about
this situation
is here's holden by himself with no one
to hold him back and of course he just
wants to go out and fix things he wants
to save the day
it doesn't register that sakai had been
working on the ship
and that he might want to check for some
kind of sabotage
it's who we know him to be and it really
emphasizes
how well the crew work together and how
they make each other better
when we see him operating on his own and
it's not a knock on holden
i find his quixotic nature to be
charming after all but
his life and the rossi itself are in
danger
and it's gonna fall on naomi over on the
pela
to sort things out over there we see a
little bit of marco trying to win her
over to his side
he tries to convince her that philip
needs that and essentially tries to use
her motherhood against her
we see sin try to stand up for her and
then we see marco have a conversation
with philip where he tells him that it's
all right to feel what he feels but not
to let those feelings rule him
and this does a pretty good job to lay
out how marco controls the people around
him
there's an amazing exchange between sin
and naomi in the hall
he tries to get her to help him do some
work to get her mind off of what's going
on
she loses it with him and he lays out
the reality of things from the belter's
perspective
through that you could really see how
people would buy into these ideas
and the only real counter that naomi has
is that
marco is building this new world for
belter children
on a river of blood when she walks away
we can see the conflict on sin's face
but at this point after the rocks have
fallen there is no turning back for the
free navy
later naomi has a conversation with
karol where she brings some truth
first and most important for naomi marco
will never let her go
she says that the only way naomi's ever
going to leave this ship is dead
and we can see through dominique
tipper's face that naomi understands
this to be true
the other thing is for us the viewers
she gives more background on the august
and gomorrah code that naomi wrote that
was first used to destroy that ship
may have been used since then to destroy
hundreds or even thousands of
ships and as we'll see naomi put it
together it's what sakai used to try to
destroy the rossi
naomi pockets a knife she goes looking
for marco with the intention of killing
him
on their screens we can see that they're
watching the rocinante
phillip grabs her before she can get
close and try to stab
marco he takes her away and on the lift
he tells her that he saved her and we
could see that she's putting that
together
and we can imagine that it's at this
moment that she realizes they sabotage
the rossi with that code and that holden
is in danger if he tries to take off
she goes to find sin gets him to drop
his guard
hits him with a wrench takes his hand
terminal and is able to get a hold of
jim in time
to tell him to shut down the reactor
that lands her in an actual
cell and it means that the rossi can't
go anywhere until they go through
and check everything to undo whatever it
is that sakai had
done elsewhere bobby and alex are still
trailing the bar keith they follow them
as they change course
towards the hungarian asteroids there
they meet up with a lot of ships that
appear to be the free navy
we don't see them identify the
individual ships but we do
see that the bar keith takes off he says
burning away from the sun
and the two escort ships remain with the
free navy
so bobby makes the conclusion that that
was what they were there to drop off
we don't get to find out anymore about
what's going on because they get spotted
this leads to a crazy high g chase here
comes the juice
that alex isn't able to maneuver his way
out of they're being chased by a torpedo
so they have to dump the ship's core
in order to destroy it they're able to
pull that off and the episode ends as we
watch them float away from the impact
i thought this was a great follow-up
episode to the big shocker that was
episode 4. if you go back and you watch
holden's call to naomi
as he lays all these things out it's
just crazy to think about what's
happening
and like i said it's important to
remember that this is all very recent
the effects of the rocks aren't clear
yet and there hasn't been enough time
past where the characters have really
been able to let that sink in
and they're all faced with these crazy
situations as a result of what happened
we see echoes of this on the razorback
or should i say the screaming fire hawk
as they're watching the news feeds there
people are just starting to put it
together that the attack on the martian
parliament the attack on tycho station
and the giant asteroids that just hit
earth are all
part of a coordinated attack by a belter
a belter of all people how would a
skinny be able to pull something like
this
off there were so many great character
moments in this episode and one of the
things that i keep running into as a
book reader
is the inevitable loss of the internal
dialogue
which you know has to go when you adapt
this for the screen they have to find
other ways to get those same things
across i think what really stood out as
far as the acting was concerned on this
episode
of how skillfully some of these actors
were able to pull that off with their
facial expressions with their body
language
i think it stood out the most for me
with sakai in the scene i mentioned
earlier
and naomi on the pella in that whole
situation in the book we get to know
what she's thinking as she's trapped
inside the ship if i try to pretend that
i don't know that
and look at it objectively i think they
do a pretty good job
i will say the way that she contacted
the rossi in the book is way better than
what happened here
but they set up sin enough and their
connection that it meant something when
she tricked him and hit him with the
wrench
and i thought it mostly worked at the
same time i knew the rossi was
compromised with sakai's code
which made it a lot easier for me to
figure it out as i'm watching
so i'd be interested to hear from people
who are just watching the show if they
were able to put that together
and knew what was going on as it was
happening i'm really enjoying seeing the
reactions come in
and seeing the contrast across the
different groups that we're following
i think amos's answer to peaches when
she says what do we do
now and he just says yeah repeating what
he had just said a few seconds ago
it really drives home the uncertainty of
everything and the other thing that i
thought stood out was the conversation
on drummership where they said that they
read that they were dancing in the
corridors of series and palace
when she says she doesn't believe that
her partner says the inners will believe
that
all the belters are the same to them so
they're doing a good job of setting up
the blowback there
i really loved the chase scene with the
razorback watching alex and bobby
fighting the high g
the show obviously had to take their
foot off the gas a little bit to
re-establish everything
so i really liked how they ratcheted
things up on the pella
and topped it off with this chase with
more mystery about the martians
i'm so ready for amos and pizzas to hit
the road so there's going to be a lot of
stuff to discuss when i preview the next
episode
in the video i'll make in the next
couple of days after some reflection
we'll talk about where all the
characters ended up
what their situations mean and where
things might be going
i think that's a good place to leave
things so let's continue the
conversation in the comments
what were your favorite moments in
episode five what story are you most
interested in
right now what are you hoping to see
what do you think's going on with the
martians what do you think's going on
in marco anara's head and we didn't see
any avasarala this episode so what do
you think is going to happen with her
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and check back in a
couple of days for another follow-up
video
i'm also going to be doing a book
discussion video this week i think so if
you read the books check that out
and if you want to talk book spoilers in
the comments please just mark those
i'm always happy to talk about the books
but i don't want to spoil anybody who
hasn't read them
so thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon